[Music]
you
was cracking you bad [ __ ] uncle
Joey at Wednesday August 3rd swingin
dick and giving our lunchboxes you
understand me
it's the only way the [ __ ] go my
balls spoof dog from last night we let
the black horse alone a damn resina
cracking some jokes di disdain only sigh
hat
Joe Perez all that's missing was you got
Sun is bright but the [ __ ] it's a
beautiful day to be alive you kicking
[ __ ] that's all that matters none
broke Joey I have psychological property
you give me feel alive [ __ ] you
got psychological problems solo one I
will turn Oh Bonnie and I just smoked
reefer in the [ __ ] eye to understand
Saint Narada killer and [ __ ] Jarl
there besides just a wreck the whole
hummed a very chill I got a full
schedule halfway through my man to pick
me up right now
put a little writing group then I come
back then I got your kitchen then I will
talk to some [ __ ] here
Mook and a half and I had a podcast and
I got a big big daughter let me know the
essentials brother you got it right you
got a right nine your gold you gotta
read a little bit and [ __ ] expand
hey that's what we most importantly
that's the top of the viola now rented
by CB dese I got my mohammad no [ __ ]
small DM me I'm ready to [ __ ] rock
had washed out my nose all the old
[ __ ] snots and now it's about us we
just did a ball of this [ __ ] voodoo
lounge over here which I have been
[ __ ] falter cuz it's got the strength
of ten divorce woman
the PR that means [ __ ] Puerto Ricans
I love it this is my best part of my day
I'm filling up those first couple bowls
getting the thoughts in my mind that's
what I [ __ ] enjoy
Chace [ __ ] pokey man
I talk about the presidential campaigns
has no effect in your [ __ ] life
and then we are just breathing the Holy
Smoke of love here the stamping that's
it that's all this is the Holy Smoke of
love
once they blow it on you and you change
your look oh no what
what have they been thinking for all
these [ __ ] years but this is it this
as good as it gets we're just hanging
out of here smoking a few bowls chitchat
from that people pay them to this [ __ ]
here we are doing it how to [ __ ] love
we're gonna nice and easy
[ __ ] it if they can't take a joke take a
[ __ ] skateboard I'm saying
if you can't take a joke take the funk
it's game boy this is as good as it gets
unless you got bumpers and people
massaging your toes do we [ __ ] like that
which not a lot he is do because if you
did you wouldn't be our [ __ ]
periscope right now I wouldn't be our
[ __ ] periscope if I had something cut
my toenails rubbing my calves and
rolling my joints of light my cigarettes
people call him a [ __ ] Monsieur
[ __ ] like that but we have each other
and that's the most important thing we
bought realize how pointless by this we
have each other
some people that hang our people to fake
[ __ ] reasons they might do something
listen we got each other
what joel osteen toward someone broken
band uh was the other guy he must've
walked through goals and time to think
that I got I got the answer right here
you do tune into this with me but they
it comes into focus
no more [ __ ] animal models [ __ ]
fake pills [ __ ] up your mind this is
it right here two three back into this
[ __ ] for five days a week I set your
[ __ ] cocksuckin [ __ ] astray I'm
saying no more [ __ ] nightmares but
whistles are go away that's it it's just
[ __ ] live it knowing Joey this is
tremendous I'm seeing it for what it is
yet you want yes you [ __ ] it on thank
y'all bull joy would do you wrong
what type of do but I'd [ __ ] Beyonce
here we go nobody gets their feelings
hurt right all right now that buddy's
picked me up we stopped we got a coffee
like regular [ __ ] yeah
Gentile they say whenever they gotta say
that's it that's sitting that's them
this is - this is as good as you take
that you know one cuz it's [ __ ] view
there's nothing here no money to spend
can't buy nothing always it though is
what each other on the I keep smoking
[ __ ] wheel excessive love the
understand because it's Wednesday
[ __ ]
during that time to be [ __ ] around
you know the art of riding and for
enterprising whatever the [ __ ] you do
you gotta get out back
gonna get yeah his dirty out of all of
your slaves that Dolly's [ __ ]
either you give it to me I'll take
little [ __ ] how you like me now [ __ ]
all right that's it we have to talk
about Lotte today talk about what's
important how important you are
[ __ ] all these [ __ ] get your
shoes on get out there get out there
steal a muffler I don't give a [ __ ] but
you gotta do it better look the [ __ ] it
doing now concert but the Maharishi said
I don't give a [ __ ] what the Maharishi
said as the Maharishi ever done [ __ ]
kidnap bait on the mutton you don't know
what it is to be [ __ ] hungry don't say
and to wanna snort blog wanna get your
dicks up jump up and down like snoop
that's a certain type of dream
I want to be around to pick up the
pieces when somebody breaks your heart
and that's it it's [ __ ] Wednesday you
got a job to do
eight o'clock tonight tomorrow night at
[ __ ] flappers at 9:15 Saturday
night the Cherokee Casino Oklahoma City
and then next Thursday listen listen you
reefer headed [ __ ] with
Colorado well it's all over with
shutting down [ __ ] that Street well
it's just [ __ ] to stay outside and smoke
briefly in the stem and that's it so
then we get ready only I know [ __ ]
stories when I get there next week
alright you escaped what broke without a
[ __ ] you have to tell me
have a good day don't let nobody [ __ ]
with you look him in the eye and tell me
suck my dick we'll call me shorty I was
born in 1940 understand me and the
conversation